i'm pleased to say we're joined once
again by the housing secretary robert
genwick mr janet good to have you in the
studio this morning um
clearly a lot to discuss around the
situation in kent but
but let's start with a not unrelated
topic um brexit
and the state of players regards the the
trade negotiations
can you just be as candid as you
possibly can be about the likelihood
of us getting a deal this side of the
new year not even this side of christmas
well i'm still reasonably optimistic but
there's no news to report to you this
morning they're still
the same serious areas of disagreement
whether that's on fisheries or
the level playing field we're working
through those issues our negotiators
will keep going the primary's been very
clear
that he's going to negotiate until the
very end which is the 31st
of december because that's the right
thing i think that's what the british
public would expect
but at the moment there isn't sufficient
progress it isn't a deal that the prime
minister feels that
he can sign us up to because it doesn't
yet
respect us in full as a sovereign
independent nation
do you see therefore as indeed some of
your colleagues in the conservative
party do a link
between what has been happening as
regards the border with france
and the brexit negotiations well i hope
not
i mean you you can see that countries
react in different ways to
uh covert and we ourselves have put
restrictions on
other countries at times when the facts
have changed and we've wanted to
uh to fully understand and appraise
those before coming to a balanced
judgment
here france was relatively unusual the
european
commission itself advised the european
union member states
not to pursue travel bans of this kind
and that may well have played a role in
reaching the resolution that we did last
night
but am i correct to detect or on your
part and perhaps more so from the prime
minister and the words that have been
expressed
more than a degree of frustration about
the way that the french have handled
this
well i think we we have had productive
discussions
over the last 24-48 hours they have
reached
uh what seems like a sensible way
forwards
uh there's going to be quite a lot of
work to do in the next few days and this
isn't going to be an issue it will be
resolved
immediately as you've heard from your
correspondent
i i wish events hadn't played out in the
way they have but but they have
we now have to move on and ensure that
traffic can flow as quickly as possible
across the channel
part of the solution obviously with
france's is testing
when do we believe that we will be
seeing people getting onto the ferries
as a result of these tests well i hope
that this morning
you'll see people and htvs crossing the
channel at the short straights
we're putting in place the
infrastructure so the armed forces will
be doing that in the first instance to
help us to set that up
and to get through some of the backlog
that you've seen they will then in turn
hand over to civilians who will take
this forward
we have a good operation in kent that's
been tested
very significantly in the last few days
led by the kent resilience forum but it
has
performed well so the work that had been
done over a number of years to create
the facility at mountain airport to
create operation stack on the motorway
has worked quite successfully but there
is now a great deal to do
but the procedures are there there will
be testing at manston and at multiple
other locations
if you test positive using the the swift
lateral flow test you'll then be offered
a pcr test so you can get an even more
refined
outcome if you test positive again you
will then be offered covert secure hotel
accommodation
and we've procured the first one of
those not so far away so
the hgv drivers will be able to drive
there leave their lorry there
and self-isolate for the 10 days before
they're then able to
cross the channel successfully can we be
specific then how many vehicles
and therefore how many drivers do we
think are currently in kent
in need of these tests well as of uh the
seven at seven pm last night which the
last figures that i saw uh there were
just under 3 000
htvs parked at manston airport and there
were about
seven to 800 in other settings as part
of our operations
so operations stack uh where they're
parked on the m20
but there may be as you've you've
reported that
other hgvs and smaller vehicles are
parked elsewhere in kent because they've
chosen not to come
into the official operation so the the
true number may be slightly higher than
that
that's a sign whatever the number is
whether it's 4 000 or more
it's a significant number to work
through so the message from grant shaps
the transport secretary last night
is an important one that if you are an
hgv driver if you're thinking of
crossing
uh the short straights don't come to
kent just yet
hold off until we've worked our way
through most of that backlog
it won't speed up your journey in fact
you'll just likely get stuck in
something that's unfortunate and you'd
be better off staying where you are but
just
just on something you said there this is
gonna this process is gonna take days
isn't it to clear the backlog as you
just i think it will take a few days
to work our way through and that by
necessity means that
the delays and the issues with the
supply chain they are not coming to a
conclusion anytime soon either well they
will
ease up because i hope that hcv's will
be crossing the channel
uh this morning and so the position will
start to gradually improve
but i think it will take time we have
put all the resources as i say the armed
forces and others
are working very hard to resolve this
but just on the wider point about supply
chain
it is an issue you know i don't i don't
dispute that but
for members of the public you know it is
important to remember with respect to
food
that there is no material shortage of
food the supermarkets have all come out
to say
that their supply chains are robust if
we all behave
you know rationally if we all just shop
for what we need for christmas in the
normal way
there shouldn't be any problem
whatsoever what does the situation as
regards the testing of
of holly's drivers what does that what
effect does that have on people
wishing to travel to the continent to
france in the future
are we gonna all gonna have to take a a
test before we cross borders
well for the next uh few days
this this this uh protocol that we've
agreed
will stay in place i think until the 6th
of january will be reviewed on the 31st
of
december so for that relatively short
period you will need to
go to the border armed with a negative
lateral flow test that's been conducted
in the last 72 hours
if you want to cross whether you're an
hgv driver or somebody else
of course travel is um discouraged at
the moment so the
relatively few people will be crossing
the border they'll likely either be
people who are going
for a good reason because they're uh hgv
drivers or bus drivers trained drivers
or they'll be returning citizens but
that continent but
that that cut-off date of the sixth of
january i mean of course you know
the the european union may well decide
to to extend
the period for which they're they're
demanding this kind of testing well
we've got no reason
to believe that this this arrangement's
been put in place relatively swiftly
it'll be kept under review
of course all over europe and indeed the
world people
are now thinking carefully about this
variant and other variants
which are likely to be quite prevalent
in a number of european countries so it
may well be that over the course of
the remainder of the month a different
conclusion is reached
let's talk about community testing shall
we 17 areas have been identified as
as an additional additional sites for
the rollout of community testing
can we just be clear about this the
areas that you have picked
for this testing are areas which are at
risk of greater restriction
well they are they are the areas where
the virus is
uh strongest where it's rising fast
where there are particular challenges
like it may be rising fast amongst the
over 60s the people who are most likely
to be unwell we want to target our
resources in the places where it's
needed the most
uh it's also a significant effort doing
this for the local councils
uh for the local nhs and so they won't
want to do this lightly
so we're focusing the effort in the
places that need it the most but you
will have seen the papers this morning
and widespread reporting that there will
be areas moving into tougher
restrictions perhaps all the way to tier
four
on boxing day when can we expect that
announcement
well we don't have a a timetable for
that the government's coveted operations
committee
is meeting later today to review further
evidence we keep this under review we're
constantly
hearing from our scientific advisor
about what we should do
the new variant i think is very worrying
the situation with the virus was
concerning before that
but the new variant is very concerning
it's only been five
days since we learned about its true uh
transmissibility
the level of concern we have more face
with it and we have more evidence
it is very concentrated in london and
the southeast
but we've also heard now that it's
prevalent in probably in most regions of
the country albeit to a lesser extent
and so it may be necessary to take
further action may be necessary to take
further action but there will be those
who say look friday
we heard about this saturday london and
the south east went into tier 4 lockdown
that doesn't seem to be the same impetus
that doesn't seem to be the same
drive to get other areas which may be at
risk of
widespread transmission into that kind
of state of lockdown again well we moved
very rapidly for the places of your your
discussions not just london
it's london and uh you know there's the
wider south east and a number of other
places like peterborough for example
they're a little bit further afield we
moved swiftly to do that the prime
minister only received
the clear advice on friday the code
operations committee met friday and
saturday
a decision was made and announced
saturday afternoon
we've now had time to think again about
whether further action is required in
other parts of the country
and that's the decision that the prime
minister and other ministers will need
to take
uh in the next couple of days the new
variant as i say
is much less prevalent elsewhere but
there is rising evidence that you can
find it in a range of other parts of the
country and so
the question is whether we should take
action now to try to head that off yeah
but but literally now i mean we are
we're about to see people who are not in
tier four areas have
not a normal christmas by any means we
all admit that
but there will be households sharing
households mixing
indoors in the environments in which we
understand the first variant of code 19
spread most rapidly the question is why
are we not doing this now and why are we
still permitting
large parts of the country many millions
of people
to mix together well we have taken
action in the rest of the country
there are only one or two places which
are currently in tier one which is the
most
uh relaxed form of restriction vast ways
of the country are in tier three
where they are facing significant
challenges which uh were considered
uh very tough until right until the last
week when we met we've added tier four
to the mix
so it's not as if the rest of the
country is having an easy ride
all parts of the country have clear
guidelines and rules to follow
the best thing everyone can do at home
regardless where they live
is to continue following the guidance as
best they possibly can
and christmas is going to be very
different whether you live in cornwall
or in central london either way
you're not going to meet many people and
we're asking people
outside of tier 4 areas to exercise
great care only to come together with a
small number of people
and only for christmas day if we need to
change that in light of the new variant
then we won't hesitate to do so what do
you make of them nicola sturgeon
and and her apology for for her breach
of the covered rules in scotland now we
all understand that there are breaches
large and small over previous weeks but
when
you know a politician doesn't interest
seems to peak what's your view
well i don't think it's it's helpful for
me to to comment on
other individuals you know a lot lots of
people make mistakes
it's it's never easy we're all human
beings at the end of the day
um but we all have to learn from that
and try our best to follow the
guidelines because we can see that
we're not just doing this for ourselves
we're doing it for for wider
society as well minister good to see you
this morning thanks for being with us
and
i should of course wish you a happy
christmas because we will not be seeing
you before then i'm sure
do take care thanks just a reminder that
if you want to catch up on
any of that interview or watch the
programme when you're out and about this
morning plenty of ways in which you can
do so you can find us on the mobile app
you can head to the website and click on
the button
go into the live blog and you can watch
the program live you can even switch on
your telly
our political correspondent kate mccann
was listening into our discussion with
mr generic uh we'll let out to you
i tell you what that almost the very
last thing that robert janrick said to
you there
i think is fascinating because you were
talking about other people mixing
outside of tier 4
over christmas having a family christmas
relatively if you're in a lower tier
and he said if we need to change that in
light of the new variant we won't
hesitate to do so
that's a government minister saying that
potentially
there could be changes to people's
christmases just a couple of days before
christmas
that tells you how seriously they are
now considering potentially moving
people into tier iv now there is a
suggestion that that would happen on
boxing day
it wouldn't happen over christmas but i
think from that conversation
what's really clear is that the
government is now even more worried
about this new variant than we thought
well you you will have seen the same
data that i have seen those reasonable
worst case scenarios
uh plotted by the government's own data
and we are looking you know if
if nothing changes by february you know
at deaths
in excess of 5000 a week i mean there is
a real sense of urgency in the
scientific community
we're just waiting to see what the
politicians do with this yeah and we're
also waiting for data remember
crucial data because we know that as
robert jamerick said there that london
in the southeast is where this new
variant has been
focused at the moment we also do know
that it has spread outside of those
areas it's very
prevalent in wales for example but the
question is how prevalent and i don't
think that was clear from robert jenwick
there i don't think he was clear about
how prevalent the virus is
outside of those areas and that's going
to be key to finding out what happens
next and how
quickly that does happen because we saw
some data yesterday provisional data in
the north west
that this is now growing that there's
been an exponential rise of cases there
if that is the case for the rest of the
country i wouldn't be surprised if we
did see some action taken today
whether or not it comes in over
christmas or boxing day is another
matter well if you hear about any